- On this Wednesday Checkup,
I want to talk about
the two urgent care doctors
that are making headlines
for their controversial
statements regarding COVID-19.
(dramatic music)
This all started on April 22
when two doctors Dan Erickson
and Artin Massihi called
a press conference
to discuss their thoughts on COVID-19
and the re-opening of America
based on the five thousand
patients they tested
in their Urgent Care centers.
The main takeaways from the
press conference are as follows:
One, the government is horribly
mishandling this situation
by ignoring the science and only focusing
on controlling the public.
Two, way more people
are sick with COVID-19
than is currently reported.
Three, the fatality rate
of COVID-19 is much lower
than currently being reported
and it's similar to the flu.
And finally four, that
America should re-open now
because the harms of keeping it closed
much outweigh the benefits.
In the days following
their press conference,
they received nationwide attention.
Mostly because their
recommendations and opinions were
in stark contrast with the
medical community and the CDC.
Also the video of the press conference
became increasingly
popular on social media
where it picked up over five
million views on YouTube.
And it received retweets
from popular figures
like Elon Musk who supported the doctors.
Fast Forward to April 27th
and YouTube has now taken
the video down stating
that it's broken community guidelines,
basically saying there's a
lot of misinformation in it.
And there's been a
joint statement released
by the American College
of Emergency Physicians
and the American Academy
of Emergency Medicine.
Let me read that statement.
The AACP and AAEM jointly
and emphatically condemn
the recent opinions released
by Dr Erickson and Dr Massihi.
"These reckless and untested
musings do not speak
"for medical society and are inconsistent
"with current science and
epidemiology regarding COVID-19.
"As owners of local urgent care clinics,
"it appears these two
individuals are releasing biased,
"non-peer reviewed data to
advance their personal financial
"interests without regard
for the public's health."
I completely agree with these statements
because these individuals presented
so much misinformation that
it's further gonna confuse
the general public.
Let me explain why the information
these doctors presented
is just not scientifically accurate.
Look, the fact that they
tested 5,000 patients
in their Urgent Care centers and 6%
of them tested positive for
COVID-19 makes a lot of sense.
And it's actually probably accurate.
But what's not accurate and
what doesn't make sense is
to then take 6%, that number
and assume that if you test
all of New York State
and all of California,
then 6% of those people
will also test positive.
That's just not how statistics work.
The people that go to
an Urgent Care center
are more likely to test positive
because they're showing symptoms,
because they likely had
exposure to COVID-19,
that's why they're there.
In general when you're testing
a preselected population
like that, you're gonna
have higher numbers.
It's like assuming that if
you go to Southern California
and gather the weather data,
you can then extrapolate it
and assume that the weather
is the same in New York.
And then with the incorrect
assumption that 6%
of the general public
must be COVID positive,
they go on to calculate a fatality rate
that's similar to the flu.
Let me go ahead and explain
to you how we calculate
a death rate so it all makes sense.
First we take all the people
who've died with COVID-19
and we divide that
number by all the people
who've been infected by COVID-19.
Let's run an example here.
If 10 people have died of COVID-19
and 1000 have been infected,
you divide 10 by 1000 and you get 1%.
It makes a 1% death rate.
Now if you incorrectly
assume that way more people
have had COVID-19 than is true,
you can artificially
lower this death rate.
My second issue is let's go ahead
and assume there calculations are correct.
They're not.
It doesn't change the fact
that COVID-19 is still
much more dangerous than the flu.
Reason being that COVID-19
spreads at a two to three times
faster rate than the flu.
Which means that it can
overwhelm our hospital systems
in the blink of an eye.
In fact, that's what the purpose
of all these lock downs were.
To ease the strain on our hospital systems
so we can continue taking care of patients
that are not only suffering with COVID,
but with all the other
medical ailments out there.
If you have been in a car accident,
there would have been no one to help you.
If you call for a heart attack,
We must also remember that for
the flu, we have a vaccine.
We have an FDA approved treatment.
So by maintaining the lockdown
for slightly longer period
of time, we're buying time
in order to get there.
To get the vaccine and to get
the treatments authorized.
These are all the reasons why
I've been consistently saying
on my YouTube channel, to
my patients, on television,
that while COVID-19 looks
similar to the flu, it's a virus,
upper respiratory symptoms,
they are not the same.
They're fundamentally different
in that COVID-19 spreads
so quickly and puts
such a tremendous strain
on our health care system,
that it can break it.
In fact, I'd love for these
emergency medicine physicians
who are no longer working
in emergency rooms
to come to New York City
and talk to the ER doctors
that are working on the front
lines to see how overwhelmed
they were with this apparently
mild virus during it's peak.
Let's move on to the topic
of re-opening America.
These individuals are adamant
about re-opening America, right now.
Because they're talking about
the negative consequences
that are happening as a
result of this lockdown.
Social issues, like domestic
violence and child abuse.
Patients not being able to get care
because they are worried
about getting sick with COVID.
Routine procedures being re-scheduled.
Economic harms.
All of these negative
consequences are very true.
And we need to take
them into consideration
when we're weighing the benefits
versus harms of a lockdown.
The last thing we want to do is to rush
to re-open America haphazardly
and see a spike in the
resurgence of COVID-19 cases.
Possibly destroying
our health care system,
potentially putting thousands
if not millions of lives
at risk because they might not be able
to get care at a hospital.
Look we absolutely need
to start taking steps
in re-opening America.
If we continue this for much longer,
it is gonna be limited benefits
and more harms being added on.
But the way we do this is strategically.
We open certain areas first,
and we continuously
gather information to see
what impact we're having
on COVID-19 numbers.
And then use that data
to gradually re-open
the country slowly, carefully,
and most importantly, safely.
At the end of the day, no one benefits
from keeping America closed.
In fact this whole theory of politicians
keeping America closed
just to keep control
over the general public is nonsensical.
They're getting hurt by this too,
and so are their families.
If you're gonna be a public
facing medical professional
that goes on to talk
about COVID-19 and say
that you're talking about science.
At least do it accurately, and
keep the politics out of it.
These doctors aren't the first
to be spreading
misinformation about COVID-19.
So are politicians and so is the media.
Click here for those videos
and as always stay happy and healthy.
(dramatic music)